most people try to create a new personal
reality as the same personality and it
doesn't work we literally have to become
someone else in other words thoughts are
the language of the brain and feelings
are the language of the body and how you
think and how you feel creates a state
of being so most people have experiences
in their life that brand them
emotionally they feel fear they feel
anger they feel bitterness they feel
frustration they feel insecurity and
those emotions then become part of their
identity so once they think certain
thoughts that turn on certain circuits
in their brain that are equal to their
insecurity and then they feel insecure
the moment they feel insecure they think
more insecure thoughts which makes more
chemicals for them to feel insecure and
the repetition of that cycle over time
conditions the body to subconsciously
become the mind of insecurity so then
the person says I am insecure and
whenever you say I am anything you're
commanding your mind and body towards a
destiny hey it's Evan Carmichael and I
make these videos because as a young
entrepreneur I struggle to keep my
business going I had no friends I had no
mentors I had no role models and the
thing that saved me was learning from
the success stories of famous
entrepreneurs and in their stories I got
motivation and I also got strategies for
what I could do to grow my business and
not stay stuck and I still need their
stories for motivation today so today
let's learn how to manifest like Joe
dispenza enjoy
so then most people's
biology is for the most part their past
and so if you're not being defined by
the vision of the future some new
possibility in your life you're only
left with the old circuitry in your
brain and the old emotions of the past
so the question then is
can you believe in a future
that you can't see or experience with
your senses yet
but you've thought about enough times in
your mind
that your brain is literally changed to
look like the experience has already
occurred now the latest research in
Neuroscience says you can change your
brain just by thinking
so then as you begin to think about a
new possibility and your brain begins to
fire in new sequences and new patterns
and new combinations and you begin to
plan your behaviors and you begin to
review in your mind mentally rehearse
who you're going to be in your life the
mere action of mental rehearsal begins
to install the neurological circuits in
your brain now your brain is no longer a
record of the past
now it's in fact a map to the Future
and if you were then to begin to
emotionally embrace your future before
it's made manifest in other words
you're not waiting for your healing to
feel wholeness you're not waiting for
your new relationship to feel love
you're not waiting for the mystical
moment to feel awe you're not waiting
for your success to feel empowered
that's the old model of reality of cause
and effect in other words
the materialist
the person who's waiting for their
wealth to come to feel abundance
they're living by that model of cause
and effect but the quantum model is
about causing an effect which means you
begin to experience your own worthiness
and your abundance before it occurs you
have to feel wholeness in order for your
healing to occur we have to feel love
for ourselves and love for life in order
for us to have love in our life and so
then to instruct people how to teach
their body emotionally how that future
could feel like before it's made
manifest
if they do it properly their body is the
unconscious mind begins to believe it's
living in that future reality in the
present moment and they're beginning to
Signal new genes in new ways that begins
to change their body to look like the
event has already occurred so the
process of change
and the meditative model requires
unlearning and relearning requires
breaking the habit of the old self and
Reinventing a new self what we say in
Neuroscience pruning synaptic
connections and sprouting new
connections unfiring and unwiring and
re-firing and rewiring
unmemorizing emotions that are stored in
the body and then reconditioning the
body to a new mind into a new motion no
longer signaling the same genes in the
same way but signaling new genes in new
ways
beginning to pull your energy out of the
past and beginning to invest your energy
into the future rule number two is write
down your goals clearly you started to
write down
all the things you were going to do
to get to that vision
all the choices you were going to make
all of the experiences or goals you
wanted to achieve
and all of the emotions and the joy you
would feel
and when you were doing that
you were setting your sights towards
that Destiny and then you did something
really brilliant
you wrote down the choices you weren't
going to make
he became aware of the behaviors you
weren't going to demonstrate
you began to review certain experiences
you wanted to stay away from
and then you looked at the emotions that
would bring you to a lower level
and you begin to separate the old self
from the new self
and when you begin to do that and you're
observing the old self
it means you're no longer the program
now you're the Consciousness observing
the program
and that's when you begin to objectify
your subjective self
now reason this let's say you've had
some pretty rough experiences in your
past
and those experiences cause you to feel
sad and unworthy and guilty
and judgmental
and you've gotten so used to feeling
guilty and unworthy and judgmental that
that's just feels normal to you
and then because you feel kind of
victimized
then you blame people and you complain
and you make excuses and you feel sorry
for yourself and that's your personality
and all of a sudden you say today
I'm not going to do that any longer
because that's the old self
and then you start off your day and it
goes really well for about two hours
and then all of a sudden the moment you
realize that you're no longer making the
same choices as the day before you are
going to feel uncomfortable
it's going to feel unfamiliar
it's going to be uncertain there's going
to be some unpredictability
and we now know that people would rather
hold on to their guilt and unworthiness
than to step into the unknown
because at least they can feel something
and so the moment you stop making the
same choices that you always make get
ready because it's going to be
uncomfortable and that's the moment
you're heading towards the new self
and we call it stepping into the river
of change rule number three is create
your personal reality our simple model
is that
your personality creates your personal
reality that's it and your personality
is made up of how you think
how you act and how you feel so the
present personality who's listening to
this podcast has created the present
personal reality called their life which
means that if you want to change your
life you want to create a new person in
reality you're gonna have to change your
personality you're going to have to
change because nothing changes in your
life until you change
so what is the understanding of change
that we've spent over 10 years studying
a way to explain what change is because
if you think 60 to 70 000 thoughts or
however many thoughts in one day and 90
of those thoughts are the same thoughts
as the day before you're in trouble
because the same thoughts will lead to
the same choices the same choices will
lead to the same behaviors the same
behaviors create the same experiences
and the same experiences produce those
very same emotions and those same
emotions influence our same thoughts and
our biology our neural circuitry our
neurochemistry our hormones or gene
expression
our immunes everything stays the same
because we're the same so it has
traditionally taken crisis or trauma or
loss for someone to make up their mind
to change so the moment we decide to
change okay I want to create a new
personal reality a new life
I got to change my personality well this
concept called metacognition we have
four brain function you know the seat of
our conscience our frontal lobe allows
us to think about what we're thinking
about to notice how we're behaving and
and to become aware of how we're feeling
and
the the repetition of thinking acting
and feeling in the same way causes our
brain to become hardwired into very
specific neural patterns right so that
that firing and wiring over time cause
us causes us to be happen so
automatically that we're unconscious
of our conscious self so the moment we
become conscious of those thoughts the
moment we become aware of those
behaviors the moments we notice those
feelings we're no longer the program in
fact where the Consciousness observing
the program and that's the first step to
change so when you decide
and become so conscious the word
meditation I looked it up
the symbol means to become familiar with
that's all it means it means
familiarization so if you become so
familiar with I can it's too hard I'll
never change no one loves me you become
aware that you are blaming complaining
you all all day long and talking trash
about somebody you notice all of a
sudden that this feeling that you're
feeling every single day that you're so
accustomed to is really guilt or shame
or unworthiness the moment you're
conscious of what what you're
experiencing you know in other words
when you're inside the jar you can't
read the label right so you gotta become
conscious of that unconscious stuff you
got to see yourself Through The Eyes of
someone else the tragedy that causes you
to no longer feel like you any longer
actually causes you to look at you from
the eyes of someone else you can see
yourself more clearly because you're not
feeling like you any longer that's the
that's the big moment of change so then
when a person really can become so
conscious of their unconscious self that
they don't go unconscious again or let
me say it another way how many times do
we have to forget
until we stop forgetting and start
remembering that's the moment of change
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video I've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number four is connect to the
energy once again the signal that you're
creating
on a daily basis
is going to either work in a
constructive way or in a destructive way
and as an example if you're walking
around feeling sorry for yourself and
suffering and feeling victimized
then you're actually emanating that
signal into the field and what you're
saying is braming experience equal to my
suffering but bring it in a way that I
least expect that surprises me and
leaves no doubt that I've created this
outcome so in a sense we're not punished
for our sins we're punished by our sins
and sin is an attitude so then the
opposite is also true
when you teach people how to connect to
the energy of a future dream and be
defined by a vision of the future
instead of the memories of the past to
believe in their future more than they
believe in their past
to fall in love with their future more
than they fall in love with their past
and be able to combine that clear
intention of that future
and begin to feel the emotions of that
future before it's made manifest they're
broadcasting a whole new signature into
the field now the beauty behind that is
is that the longer you're conscious of
that energy
the more you're drawing that future to
you which also means then the moment you
get in your car and start getting angry
and getting frustrated because you're in
traffic
now you just disconnected from the
energy of your future and now you're
back to the energy of your past and
those survival emotions exert less
effects on the nature of reality so now
you feel like matter trying to change
matter you're you're separate and so you
force it you control it you try harder
you wish you pray you hope I mean hope
is a beggar we do everything compete to
try to manipulate and make it happen
because we have limited resources then
so then when a person is able to sustain
or maintain that modified state of mind
and being
then the fun starts to happen because
you start seeing those synchronicities
you start seeing those coincidences
those opportunities those unknowns those
things start falling out of nowhere
because you are connected to that field
of information and not only are you
connected to it but you're also
beginning to influence it so then more
and more people are creating now
and less of less people are experiencing
the state of being called being a victim
so then if you're a victim then you
would say I was angry because of traffic
well then I would say to you well you
mean your outer world was controlling
how you think and feel some circumstance
some person something in your outer
world is actually controlling your
feelings and thoughts that means you're
a victim to those circumstances but when
you change the way you think and feel
and it starts to produce effects in your
outer world now you start to realize
you're the creator of your life and the
moment you start seeing feedback in your
life
you're going to pay attention to what
you did and you're going to do it again
and now you're going to believe now
you're more of the creator of your life
and less of the victim of your life rule
number five is recondition your body how
do you create the life you want and how
do you begin to have you know your
subjective mind produce effects in your
objective world now the quantum model
says that the moment you begin to look
for an electron electron you know is in
a field of probabilities or
possibilities and the Observer comes
along and the observer looks and all of
a sudden Boom the electron appears it
collapses from a wave of possibilities
into an event called collapsing the wave
function that's a Quantum event
so mind and matter are somehow
correlated so the question is can you
observe
your life the way you want and cause
infinite patterns of energy to collapse
into new information called the new
experience in your life or a new Quantum
event
so for two years we taught the workshops
around the world and guess what happened
not a lot
we didn't see a lot of change every now
and then we see people's lives were
getting better here and there but what I
was after was because when I wrote what
the bleep I understood the science of
changing your mind the process of change
requires unlearning and relearning
it requires breaking the habit of your
old self and then Reinventing a new self
it's what we say in Neuroscience pruning
synaptic connections and sprouting new
connections
unmerizing emotions that are stored in
your body and then reconditioning your
body to a new mind into a new emotion to
deprogram to reprogram to lose your mind
and create a new one
to move your energy out of the past and
then use that energy to drive you to a
new future
and so I saw what people did when they
had spontaneous remissions I saw
four things that they had in common all
of them believe that there was a
spiritual aspect to them something
greater that was giving them life that
they wanted to connect to they wanted to
give that intelligence a plan a template
a design and then surrender it and allow
it to do it for them
and so I began to realize that many many
people in the world were beginning to
embrace this concept of quantum physics
and spirituality the second thing they
had in common is they all understood it
was their mismanagement of their life
that created their disease it was their
20 years of hatred their 30 years of
bitterness through 10 years of guilt
they're 45 years of anger and those
emotions they had memorized and those
emotions were driving certain thoughts
and those thoughts were reaffirming
certain emotions and how you think and
how you feel creates a state of being
thoughts are the language of the brain
feelings of the language of the body and
how you think and how you feel creates a
state of being but the redundancy of
that cycle of thinking and feeling over
time conditions your body to memorize
that emotional state as well as the
conscious mind and moment the body knows
better than the mind that's called a
habit a habit is when your body is your
mind and 95 percent of Who We Are by the
time we're 35 years old this is science
it's a set of memorized behaviors
emotional reactions beliefs and
perceptions that function like an
unconscious subconscious automatic
program so when people go to change
they're using five percent of their
conscious mind to work against 95
percent of what they've memorized and
they would think positively all they
wanted but they've been memorizing
negativity for the last 25 years where
they create their dream board you know
with their SUV and their hairstyle and
kid in the back and you know fingernails
and house and but they felt unworthy
it's mind and body and opposition
and so I realized that the very emotions
of anger and aggression and hostility
and hatred and frustration and judgment
and fear and anxiety and hopelessness
and powerlessness and depression and
insecurity are all driven by the
hormones of stress rule number six is
stop being defined by your past
meditation the actual translation of the
word meditation means to become familiar
with so the first thing you have to do
is you have to become conscious of your
unconscious thoughts you got to notice
your automatic habits and behaviors and
you have to become aware of your
emotions that keep you anchored to the
past and if you can become so conscious
of the one unconscious states of mind
and body that they would never slip by
your conscious awareness again you're
becoming familiar with the old self so
you don't return then if you begin to
think about new ways of being being
defined by a vision
plan your behaviors review them in your
mind now if you keep doing that over and
over again nerve cells that fire
together wire together you begin to
become familiar with a new state of mind
at the same time if you can emotionally
cultivate your inspiration your joy Your
Enthusiasm ahead of the experience by
repeating that over and over again
cultivating that state it's going to
begin to become familiar to you so then
the process of change then requires
unlearning and relearning breaking the
habit of the old self Reinventing a new
self
learning synaptic connections as we say
in neuroscience and sprouting new
connections unmemorizing emotions that
are stored in the body then here's the
key reconditioning the body to a new
mind into a new emotion it's literally
moving from your past to your future
it's losing your mind and creating a new
one and so then when you begin to
understand that in the in that process
it's going to feel a little bit
unfamiliar uncomfortable and if you can
relax into that instead of going back to
the past continuously invest in your
future sooner or later it'll begin to
become easier and easier and easier and
all of a sudden when you least expect it
something amazing is going to happen in
your life and when that event begins to
occur you're going to pay attention to
what you did inside of you now to
produce the effect outside of you and
that's called human empowerment and
there isn't a person in the world that's
excluded from this equation at rule
number seven the last one before some
very special bonus Clips is change your
old habits how many people in this
audience
actually believe in the idea that the
way you think has some effect on your
life that your thoughts create your life
you believe that yes
so how many people here actually woke up
this morning
and consciously created a future
you know the biggest reason why people
don't do it
is because you don't really believe it's
true
you see if you knew on a gut level that
it was absolutely true
would you ever miss a day come on
and would you ever let any thought slip
by your awareness that you didn't want
to experience
so your brain according to Neuroscience
is organized to reflect everything you
know in your life
your brain is a record of your
environment
it's a record an artifact of your past
so if you believe this then then does
your environment control your thinking
or does your thinking control your
environment
so if you wake up in the morning
and you get out of bed on the same exact
side as you did the day before you shut
the alarm clock off with the same finger
you slip into your favorite slippers you
Shuffle into the bathroom when you use
the toilet like you always do
then you walk over to the mirror and you
look at yourself to remember who you are
then you get into the shower and you
wash yourself in the same routine way
then you groom yourself to look like
everybody expects you to look
then you go downstairs and you drink
coffee out of your favorite mug
then you drive the work the same way as
you did the day before
you see the same people that push the
same emotional buttons
you do the exact thing that you know how
to do and you memorize and can do so
well that you're an expert at then you
hurry up and rush home so you can hurry
up and check your emails so you could
hurry up and go to bed so you can hurry
up and do it all over again
now here's my question did your brain
change at all that day
we could say that you are thinking the
same thoughts performing the same
actions that create the same experiences
that produce the same emotions but
secretly expecting something to change
in your life would you agree
so then
as the environment turns on different
circuits in your brain you begin to
think equal to your environment as you
see the same people and go to the same
places and do the same things at the
same time it's the external environment
that's turning on different circuits in
your brain causing you to think equal to
everything that you know
and as long as you think equal to
everything that's familiar or known to
you what do you keep creating more of
same life now the quantum law is still
applying to you you're just thinking
equal to everything that you know and
you keep creating more of the same
to change
to truly change is to think greater than
your environment and every great person
in history knew this whether it was
William Wallace or Mahatma Gandhi or
Martin Luther King or Queen Elizabeth
the first or Joan of Arc they all had a
vision
they all had an idea couldn't see it
couldn't smell it couldn't taste it
couldn't feel it but it was alive in
their mind
it was so alive in their mind that they
began to live as if that reality was
actually happening now
so can you believe in a future
that you can't see or experience with
your senses yet
but you've thought about enough times in
your mind that your brain is literally
changed to look like the event has
already happened
Neuroscience says it's absolutely
possible
Newtonian world is all about the
predictable it's all about predicting a
future but the quantum model of reality
is is about causing an effect the moment
you start feeling abundant and worthy
you are generating wealth the moment
you're empowered and feel it you're
beginning to step towards your success
the moment you start feeling whole your
Healing Begins and when you love
yourself and you love all of life you'll
create an equal now you're causing an
effect and I think that's the the
difference between living as a victim in
your world saying I am this way because
of this person or that thing or this
experience they made me think and feel
this way when you switch that around you
become a creator of your world and you
start saying my thinking and my feeling
is changing an outcome in my life and
now that's a whole different game and we
start believing more that we're creators
of reality how do we then go from that
like mechanistically
to begin this visualization process of
something that's empowering it's me in a
different state It's My Future Self is
it meditation is it what does that look
like if you're not being defined by a
vision of the future
then you're left with the old memories
of the past and you will be predictable
in your life
and if you wake up in the morning and
you're not being defined by a vision in
the future as you see the same people
and you go to the same places and you do
the exact same thing at the exact same
time
it's no longer that your personality is
creating your personal reality now your
personal reality is affecting or
creating your personality your
environment is really controlling how
you think and feel unconsciously because
every person everything every place
every experience has a neurological
Network in your brain every experience
that you have with every person produces
an emotion so some people will use their
boss to reaffirm their addiction to
judgment they'll use their enemy to
reaffirm their addiction to hatred
they'll use their friends to reaffirm
their addiction to suffering so now they
need the outer world to feel something
so
to change then is to be greater than
your environment to be greater than the
conditions in your world and the
environment is that seductive so then
why is meditation the tool well
let's sit down let's Close Our Eyes
let's disconnect from your outer
environment so if you're seeing less
things there's less stimulation going to
your brain if you're playing soft music
or you have earplugs in less sensory
information coming to your brain so
you're disconnecting from your
environment if you can sit your body
down
and tell it to stay like an animal stay
right here I'm gonna feed you when we're
done you can get up and check your
emails you can do all your texts but
right now you're going to sit there and
obey me
so then when you do that properly and
you're not eating anything or smelling
anything or tasting anything you're not
up experiencing and feeling anything you
would have to agree with me that you're
being defined by a thought right so when
the body wants to go back to its
emotional past
and you become aware that your attention
is on that emotion and where you place
your attention is where you place your
energy you're siphoning your energy out
of the present moment into the past and
you become aware of that
and you settle your body back down in
the present moment because it's saying
well it's eight o'clock you normally get
upset because you're in traffic around
this time and here you are sitting and
we're used to feeling anger and you're
off schedule oh it's 11 o'clock and
usually check your emails and judge
everybody well the body's looking for
that that predictable chemical state
every time you become aware that you're
doing that and your body is craving
those emotions and you settle it back
down into the present moment you're
telling the body
it's no longer the mind that you're the
mind and now your will is getting
greater than the program and if you keep
doing this over and over again over and
over again over and over again just like
training a stallion or a dog it's just
gonna say I'm gonna sit and the moment
that happens when the body is no longer
the mind when it finally surrenders
there's a liberation of energy
we go from particle to wave from matter
to energy and we free ourselves from the
chains of those emotions that keep us in
the in the familiar past and we've seen
this thousands of times in fact we can
actually predict it now on a brain scan
every
single thought we have or every sentence
we speak is an affirmation and it's
either positive or negative and it's
going out from us and it's creating our
experiences however when we talk about
doing affirmations what we're talking
about is making definite positive
statements to create something in our
life or to remove something in our life
you see if you stand there and say I
don't want this job or I don't want this
relationship or I don't want these hips
or I don't want whatever that does not
get you what you want that's what I call
fighting the negative and it doesn't do
anything but keep what you have that you
say you don't want however if you start
saying and doing affirmations that I
have a wonderful new job or I have this
most absolutely marvelous relationship
then you're beginning to create what it
is you do want affirmations are like
planting seeds
and if you think for a moment when you
put a seed in the ground you do not get
instant tomato plant or instant
strawberries or instant oak tree that
seed goes in the ground and it has to
germinate
that's the first thing which means it
breaks open its little shell and little
Roots begin to go down
and it gets nourishment from the Earth
and only then does the first Little
Shoot come up through the ground
now when we're doing affirmations too
often people say well that isn't a
million dollars and they stomp on that
first Little Shoot they don't give it a
chance to grow
doing affirmations is like planting a
seed in the ground and watering is it it
is like repeating your affirmations and
you just keep doing them and you keep
doing them and you keep doing them and
it doesn't matter whether you see the
results or you don't see the results and
sometimes it just takes time and too
many people will do affirmations for two
or three days and say see it doesn't
work
you know if
everything happens in the perfect time
space sequence and we want to trust that
and we want to know that so if you begin
to do affirmations for yourself and I
think it's important that we do that on
a daily basis decide what you want
and begin to do positive statements in
present tense for what you want you
never want to say I will have or I'm
going to have because if you do that it
keeps it in the future and remember if
you say I have a wonderful new apartment
and you're living in a dump it doesn't
mean that this is not a true statement
it means you are planting the seed that
will germinate and grow and become the
new apartment so you just keep doing it
no matter what where you are also if
you're leaving a situation if you're in
a job you don't like if you're in a
relationship you don't like if you're in
a a house you don't like
and you want something new begin to
bless with love
interesting blessed with love where you
are
and and know that you're releasing your
current situation with love if it's a
job release it with love to the next
person who will be delighted to have it
if it's an apartment do the same thing
if it's a relationship release that
person with love to happiness which is
Meaningful to them
and that leaves you free to create and
accept happiness that is Meaningful to
you if you expect to achieve your goals
if you expect to
reach your potential if you expect to
have your dreams come true what I'm
about to explain to you is Mission
critical you must become a master at
visualization
now for those of you
that are like what the heck is she
talking about I did not sign up for some
sort of meditation woo-woo spiritual
thing here
don't worry this is Mel Robbins there's
always science and research involved in
everything that I talk about so
visualization is a extraordinarily
powerful skill
and you may have heard of the law of
attraction
you may have heard of the word
visualization you may have heard of the
word manifesting
I call it
um
seeing signs
so I'm a master at seeing positive signs
I am a master of creating coincidences I
have the world's most incredible luck
you want to know why because I
understand the science and the skill of
visualization
so that you your brain
brain is a filter your brain is
constantly looking for evidence and
that's good news it's good news when you
know how to use it to your advantage let
me explain
so your brain has a system in it here's
the technical term it's called the
reticular activating system
it is a network of neurons all up in
here and what is the job of the
reticular activating system it is a
filter system
it's basically a system that allows
certain information in your brain and it
blocks out other information
guess
programmed that filter
[Music]
and so did the people from your past and
so if you constantly feel like you're
unlovable guess what your reticular
activating system is going through the
day and it is going to point out every
single piece of evidence that confirms
that negative belief that you have if
your goal is to improve your self-worth
I want you to visualize
what your life looks like and how you're
going to feel
about yourself
when your self-worth has improved
here's how you're going to do it so
there's two things that you have to do
when it comes to visualization
you have to close your eyes
truly I know it sounds stupid but I want
you to close your eyes and I want you to
in your mind have a specific picture
of what it looks like in your life when
your self-worth has improved you're
going to see yourself speaking up at
work you're going to see yourself
talking more about your business you're
going to see yourself leaving bad
relationships you're going to see
yourself defining boundaries you're
going to see yourself going to the gym
you're going to see yourself uh taking
care of yourself and when you start to
visualize the image of that I want you
to consciously this is step two
consciously think of the positive
emotions that you're going to feel I'm
going to feel happy
I'm gonna feel proud I'm going to stand
taller I'm going to be so grateful that
I made this change
marrying the the specific picture oh
there I am there I am I'm I'm at work
and I'm raising my hand amazing I'm
sharing my idea there I am I'm getting a
promotion there I am asking for a race
there I am I've just signed up another
customer to my business there I am I've
gone back to school I feel so good about
myself
when you do that here's what's actually
happening in your brain
this is the cool science part
you are training your brain to have a
totally different filter you see your
brain my brain it doesn't know the
difference between something that
actually happened to you like the F you
got in your test in 10th Grade
and the things you imagine that are
happening to you
let me say that again
your brain doesn't know the difference
between the bad things that actually
happen to you
the real memories that you have and an
imagined memory that you're creating
your brain will experience you
visualizing going to the gym you
visualizing how happy you feel when you
do you visualizing asking for that raise
and getting it and how proud you're
going to feel your brain when you
visualize in the way that I'm teaching
you to it it encodes it as a real memory
and that's important because when you
encode it as a real memory it changes
the filter system that reticular
activating system and here's what we
know based on research the more you
visualize things number one
the greater your confidence is going to
be
the greater security you're going to
have about it and here's the really cool
thing
the more you do this with your goals you
wake up every day and you just visualize
for it takes 30 freaking seconds for
crying out loud you visualize having a
great day at school you visualize curing
your panic and how proud you're going to
be
what studies suggest and have proven is
that simply visualizing yourself doing
things actually develops the skill
and helps you improve the skills just as
if you were actually doing it the
problem with passion is that you and I
have bought into this massive fantasy
world where we think that passion is a
person or a place or a thing that
somehow like a needle in a stay Haz and
a needle in a haystack that you are
somehow just going to stumble into the
thing and you're going to find that one
person or you're going to find that one
thing that you're meant to do or you're
going to find that career and honestly
we gotta change the way that you think
about passion and purpose
before you will actually be able to
bring it into your life because the
truth is Passion isn't in a person it
isn't in a place and it isn't in a thing
it's something inside of you and when
you flip the definition of what passion
is and when you actually understand what
you're looking for when you say I want
to discover my passion
then you'll be able to create more of it
in your life I started thinking about
luck because there are for a long time
in my life I started to think that luck
was for other people that luck was just
one of those things that if you were
lucky enough to be born with luck you
won the lottery you got the job you
wanted your family got along and the
truth is there's a tremendous amount of
science behind luck that luck is
something that you can make for yourself
that you can become luckier based on the
things that you do and the things that
you think about and one of the things
about lucky people is a lot of lucky
people make their luck because they have
trained themselves to think
optimistically and one small trick that
you can use in your life that is free
you can do it today is when you go to
bed tonight before you go to sleep I
want you to write down one thing that
happened today that was good that's it
every night before you go to bed I want
you to write down one thing that
happened today that's good in fact let's
do it right now in the comments go to
the comments and tell me one thing that
has happened today that you can think of
that's good just one thing
maybe you got up on time maybe you
didn't have traffic today on the way to
work maybe uh you haven't fought with
your kids this morning maybe you got to
the gym maybe you woke up and for the
first hour of the day you didn't make
yourself wrong all of those things while
they're really little don't dismiss them
because those are things that are good
and the reason why I want you to start a
practice where every night before you go
to bed or if you don't want to do it at
night do it in the morning every night
before you go to bed write down one
thing that happened today that was good
the reason why you're doing this is you
are training yourself to start to spot
the good believe it or not training
yourself to start to look for the good
in your life fundamentally trains your
mind away from looking at the negative
so that you start seeing this thing
that's positive about your life versus
that thing that's negative about your
life you're never ever ever ever going
to feel like doing the things you need
to do in order to have what you want
you're always going to need to push
yourself you're always going to need to
parent yourself so what is the net
advice on this what what is the bottom
line the bottom line is no one's coming
no one
no one's coming to push you
no one's coming to tell you to turn the
TV off
no one's coming to tell you to get out
the door and exercise nobody's coming to
tell you to apply for that job that
you've always dreamed about nobody's
coming to write the business plan for
you it's up to you
and because you're only ever going to do
the things that you feel like doing
right now or that feel good right now
unless you understand that you've got to
parent yourself you got to push yourself
you're not going to make your dreams
come true you're just not we're not
wired that way you weren't born that way
you weren't that way when you were
growing up and you're certainly not that
way as an adult and there's a tremendous
amount of Liberation that comes when you
accept the fact
you're always going to need to give
yourself a push the truth is if you want
control in your life if you want to make
things happen you
get a no and do it anyway so what do I
mean when I say if you want control
expect to know well there's a couple
things that I mean by it number one if
you're somebody that gets paralyzed
because you want things to be perfect
perfectionism is a way that most of us
try to handle or mitigate or make sure
that we don't hear no we assume that if
we're perfect everything's going to go
okay and so we spend all of our energy
thinking about our dating profile or
thinking about the business plan or
thinking about how to make things
perfect and the reason why we do that is
we're terrified to hear no we're
terrified to put something out there
that's not perfect because if it's not
perfect you might get a no
um one of the better ways to handle this
is to actually expect a no you know I
saw the most incredible quote by our
friend faustina
over in Australia she's very famous DJ
and friend of ours from Australia and
she put out the most amazing quote and
I'm going to get it totally wrong
um but it's something like this you have
to be yourself
because
how else are the people who are looking
for you gonna find you and I think
particularly when it comes to dating
what we tend to do is we are so afraid
of being rejected by anybody out there
that we try to be somebody that we're
not that we put out a fake improved or
what we think is improved version of
ourselves in order to not hear no and
most of us pretend to be somebody that
we're not When We Fear rejection when we
believe that how we are who we are isn't
good enough and so that's why it's so
important for you to understand that you
have to be willing to hear a no you have
to be willing to hear a no from the
wrong people so that the people that are
looking for you can find you so that the
people who want to be part of your
business can be part of your business if
you're putting a fake person out there
or a pretend perfect person out there
because you think that's gonna that's
gonna save you from rejection
you're actually screwing yourself over
you're not a procrastinator you have a
habit of procrastinating
big difference
because if it's a habit I can teach you
to use science to break it
you see all habits have three parts
there's a trigger and in the case of
procrastination the trigger is always
stress
then there's a pattern you repeat and in
the case of procrastination it is to
avoid doing something and then there's a
reward you get a little stress relief
the only way to break a habit you guys
is not to deal with the triggers
you're never going to get rid of the
stress in your life but you can 100
percent change your pattern of avoiding
work
so next time that you're in a situation
where you feel yourself hesitate you
spent way too much time checking out the
highlights from last night's scores what
you're going to do is you're going to go
up I must be stressed out about
something acknowledge the stress then go
54321 I want you to count to yourself
because I want you to interrupt The
Habit that's stored here and I want you
to awaken your prefrontal cortex then I
want you to just work just for five
minutes the reason why I want you to
only work for five minutes is because
your problem isn't working
it's the habit of avoiding I just need
you to start and here's the other cool
thing
we know based on Research that if we can
get you to start 80 percent of you are
going to keep going do it anyway is a
mindset trick that you can use when you
start to feel excuses rolling up it
works a lot like the five second rule so
you have said to yourself okay I'm going
to talk to my boss today about that
thing that I've been avoiding talking to
them about or maybe you've said
something like I'm gonna go to the gym
today or tomorrow or whatever and then
the moment comes where you've got to
have that conversation
or the moment comes where it's time to
pack up your bag and leave your desk and
go to the gym and what always happens
you don't feel like it
I bet there are plenty of you watching
that have made a commitment that I'm not
going to have a drink tonight
and then guess what happens when you get
home
you don't feel like not drinking you
feel like having a drink and so here's
what do it anyway has done for me
the idea that I just do it anyway
has pushed me to realize and to
recognize that there are a lot of
moments when there are things in my life
that I really want to do
I need to do
I should do but when the moment comes I
don't feel like it
and so I pull out this idea of you know
what I'm just gonna do it anyway
it's raining outside I said I would go
for a short run I don't feel like it I'm
gonna do it anyway it's six o'clock in
the morning I'm tired it's cold
I laid out my yoga clothes but now I
don't feel like it what do I do I do it
anyway when you start to say to yourself
I'm gonna do it anyway what happens is
something really cool you acknowledge
that there are feelings that you have
that are trying to swoop in and hijack
you
you acknowledge them and you basically
say guess what I'm gonna do it anyway
the one person that is diminishing your
ability to make these dreams a reality
is you
because when you state your dream this
is what happens you state it and then
all of a sudden you're present to how
far away you are from it and when you
see the distance between where you are
and where you want to go the direction
that your dream requires you to walk in
you're going to get presents of the Gap
and that scares us that's where fear
comes into play and you start to think
of all the reasons why you don't deserve
it you start to think of all the reasons
why you can't do it all that you have to
do in order to start to pursue your
dreams is take small actions every day
that align your life in that direction
so what does that mean if you want to
play guitar professionally it means that
you start playing Guitar more it means
that you sign up for Open Mic nights it
means that you go back to class if if
that's something that interests you you
see your dreams will happen either
because of you or in spite of you they
don't happen because of other people
they happen because of you and what you
do
the second you have The Bravery to state
that dream now are you going to create
it or are you going to diminish it in
your mind here's your new definition of
passion passion is simply energy that's
all that it is okay
passion is what you feel when you are
energized and excited about what you're
doing okay I want you to think about
that for a minute I want you to think
about a moment in time when you felt
incredibly passionate about something
okay and why don't you in the comments
tell me where are you watching from and
tell me about a moment in time when you
felt incredibly passionate about what
you were doing about where you were
about the people that you were with
describe that moment for me because when
you start to really investigate passion
as energy this is what you're going to
discover those moments when you are
super passionate like I'm sure my kids
would write down when they're doing
community theater with all their friends
I would write down whenever I'm doing
any kind of creative project with my
team I'm incredibly energized whenever
I'm doing group exercise stuff climbing
a mountain doing a 5K race doing some
sort of walkathon I'm incredibly
energized by that whenever I'm
um doing some sort of creative project
incredibly energized by that whenever
I'm working with our video team
incredibly energized by that whenever I
am coaching someone or giving advice I
am incredibly energized by that and so
what I want you to understand is that if
you look back on your life you have had
moments where you have felt passion I'm
being very deliberate in how I'm talking
this morning on coffee talk because
passion is a huge topic for so many of
you and you've been so focused on trying
to figure out what job is going to make
me uh passionate what job is my passion
what is my purpose on the earth I'm
going to tell you what your purpose on
Earth is right now your purpose on Earth
is to figure out how to align your life
so that you feel more energized and
excited by it that's it and it begins
with you following the energy and
following your natural enthusiasm you're
not going to think your way to Passion
you can't think your way to finding
something that you feel in your heart it
doesn't work that way you got to feel
your way into it it's inside of you do
you understand there's no passion out
there somewhere the passion is in here
and so what you have to do first is
you've got to stop thinking that you're
going to find it somewhere and you've
got to realize that passion is about
unlocking something that's all in you
you
born your home and then we go to
kindergarten and then you go to first
grade and then you go to second grade
and then you go to third grade and then
you go to fourth grade and then you go
to fifth grade and then you go to middle
school and then you go to high school
and then there's the pressure to go to
college or to a tech school or to do
something else and then you get your job
and then you're in your job and then you
meet somebody and then you get married
and then you're supposed to buy the
house and then you're supposed to have
the kids and maybe get the dog before
the kids or after the kids but then you
have a second kid and then you have the
0.5 kid because most of us do 2.5 kids
and then we get and then we get the the
home equity line and then we put the
kitchen Edition on and then we I mean
it's like our entire lives are set out
in this linear progression as people
Chase
the Dream the next
and particularly
for
those of us who are triggered by the
fear of losing control
it's only natural
to Anchor
your feeling of being in control to
chasing the next thing
and so not only are we all socialized to
believe that we're supposed to climb
this ladder we're supposed to do things
in a linear progression we're supposed
to
get to the next thing we've also been
marketed to
foreign
by society that will be happier if we
have a new car we'll be happier if we
have a better dishwasher we'll be
happier if we have the skin lotion
that's got the almond scent
and we're also psychologically anchoring
our sense of control and our sense of
Happiness on achieving those things and
what you're experiencing is no different
than what millions and millions and
millions of us experience
and that's that emptiness that you feel
when you buy the lotion that smells like
almond butter and it doesn't make you
happy
or you get the promotion
and you
have an extra hundred bucks in your
paycheck after taxes and it means you
can buy the 14 Chardonnay not the ten
dollar shortened Chardonnay and it
doesn't make you happy
and the reason why
is
the I'll be happy when life the chase
the carrot life the get to the next
thing life
that form of Happiness requires you to
be driving
let's use the car analogy again to be
going 60 miles an hour at all times
and happiness is achieved through a
different formula
it happens when you're sitting at the
light and you're idle when you're in the
moment doing things that make you happy
and that's being with people that you
care about it's engaging in experiences
that make you happy and it's working on
things that are important to you what
you believe about yourself is the only
thing that matters at the end of the day
no matter how much outside affirmations
you get or other people telling you that
you're amazing if you don't believe in
your heart that you are amazing it won't
none of that will last like you've ever
gone to an event or you ever made a
video or created something or you're
hanging out with a friend and they tell
you how amazing you are and that feels
good right like the external
affirmations and validation feels great
but then it fades but that stuff doesn't
last you don't have somebody being a
cheerleader for you every day showing up
in your bedroom saying hooray go do this
you're amazing right we don't have that
you have to be that for yourself
if you're constantly only getting your
value as a human being from other people
when they tell you that you're amazing
you're never gonna love your life you're
never gonna love yourself
it has to come from you has to come from
you telling yourself and you believe in
that you are amazing
okay so that's that's a lot of words how
do you actually go off and do it
so like for me it's this is why I
believe that lack of belief is the
world's number one problem
you know I can go and meet somebody and
fill them full of belief for a moment
but if they still don't believe in
themselves and they're going home back
to a life that they they had before
because they don't believe in themselves
enough
and so you have to design habits and
routines in systems and schedules to
slowly shift your belief in yourself
forward
every single day
and a good chunk of that is what you say
about yourself
when you look at yourself in the mirror
what do you say when you think about
yourself what do you say a lot of a lot
of the stuff that we say about ourselves
we wouldn't we wouldn't say to our worst
enemies it's rough
I actually think it's great to be your
own worst critic
I think it's great I think honestly I
think for a lot of people
um we're not hard enough on ourselves
let me let me stick with me for a minute
we're not hard enough on ourselves
because in order to get to where you
want to go you actually need to push
yourself more the problem is why we
can't do it is
we don't love ourselves enough we're not
our biggest cheerleader enough you have
to balance those two things we're very
hard on ourselves but because there's no
self-love we're not cheering ourselves
on enough we're not our biggest
cheerleader
you can't handle it most people are
already at the breaking point you know
like sitting here in a parking lot these
you know those I guess it's kind of
blurry you can't really see them but
people hate their lives
they're barely hanging on most people
are barely hanging on
barely hanging on to what we're doing we
we can post all these great things on
Instagram or wherever and make it look
like we're enjoying our life but most
people are barely hanging on the people
who are judging you for your life and
telling you that you suck hate their own
lives they are barely hanging on so how
do we get through it well yes we can be
harder on ourselves but we need to
balance that with more self-love
you have to remind yourself of why
you're great what you're proud of what
you're grateful for
and it has to be consistent otherwise
you'll never get to where you want to go
and when you love yourself more that
actually allows you to be harder on
yourself
when you love yourself more you actually
feel it you can push yourself harder
you can you can be more
um
demanding of yourself
because it's not going to push you over
the edge because you're not tying your
self-worth
to you accomplishing that thing and when
you don't accomplish it you feel like a
loser
it's starting from a place of I'm
amazing
that allows you to be way harder on
yourself when I go to events
a YouTube event for example if I'm
talking about anything entrepreneurship
or YouTube related
um I'm going in thinking
I'm Kick-Ass
and because I feel that I don't need to
say that
like a lot of times we feel like we need
to say that because it's it's masked and
insecurity right it's like those people
who uh
we've seen those memes where
when people make a little bit of money
they've got all these chains and
everything but then the people who are
Ultra rich
who have all the money
you look even Jay-Z like early Jay-Z you
know he's got all his change and
everything and now he's like he doesn't
care you know just walking on a T-shirt
and some jeans
because he doesn't need to front
because he's just so self-confident now
that it doesn't matter now it's actually
expression instead of masking and
insecurity most of us are just masking
insecurities instead of actually being
self-confident and so when I'm going to
an event if I'm talking about YouTube
I'm walking in feeling amazing
and I don't need to
I don't need to walk around and say hey
look at me
and it's actually the opposite I can go
up and say hey where do I suck it'll be
it's my favorite question to ask why do
I suck where do I suck can you point it
out if I can find one person to tell me
where I suck at something how my videos
suck my thumbnails suck do I don't
believe that they suck
right
I think they're amazing
but because I think they're so amazing
it allows me to go a lot harder on
myself
and so people will give their honest
opinion and say hey here's how I think
it could be better
and so I think we need to do that more
in our lives we need to cheer ourselves
up more we need to cheer ourselves on
more so how do we do it let me let me
share some practical tips for you to
execute
number one
music in the morning
every morning one of the most important
things that I do is I put music on and
it's music that makes me move makes me
dance makes me there's some songs that
came on you would have to you would have
to move
right it doesn't mean that you're up and
like dancing through the whole house
going crazy in your underwear first
thing in the morning but something that
even if it's just making your head Bob
there are songs if they came on would
make your head Bob and you'd probably be
singing maybe not out loud but singing
under your breath I'm gonna tune along
and be intentional with the lyrics
because if we're singing Out lyrics that
are negative
that has a lasting impact but if you're
singing Out lyrics that are positive
that also has a lasting impact
so be intentional with music that you
put on Every Day first start your day
with music it's the fastest way to
change your state to go from feeling low
and tired and just what what day is it
what am I doing I wake up every day like
what day is it what am I doing today
yeah it's but I demand excellence and
that that starts with music because I
don't have I don't want to spend a lot
of time trying to get into the right
state of mind I can command it whenever
I want just by putting on the right song
so be in tension with your music and the
lyrics being positive two
connect to the work that you're doing
and how meaningful it is
so the next thing I'll do is I'll take
the dogs out and then I'll go for what I
call a believe walk and it's probably
the most important part of my morning
routine is I go for a believe walk and
it's a minimum of 20 minutes and it's a
maximum of an hour
and I'll go for a walk by myself with 20
pounds on my back I'll go rucking a walk
to Tim Hortons usually get a coffee
you know this costs two bucks two
something so I only had you know what's
the what's the best money I spend every
year well it's the 700 bucks
of going on my believe walk and getting
the coffee every morning and I'm
thinking about what's my intention for
the day and I'm thinking about what I
want to accomplish today and the lives
that I want to serve and the people I
want to help and and what I'm about to
do today
and
it's a mini celebration
where most of the time we wake up like
an accident right you wake up you're
probably late for something you
immediately look at your phone what's on
your phone it's other people's demands
for your time other people's emergencies
of what they think you should do with
your schedule today right that's what's
in your phone all the DMS and the emails
and the texts and the missed calls and
all it's all other people's agenda for
your time that that is not an
intentional life we wake up like an
accident and start falling into what
other people want us to do today that's
not what you need to do and you need to
protect your time so the morning
having to believe walk for me if you
want to go on your own whether it's 20
minutes or an hour that's really just a
feel thing too I don't book anything
until 10 30 at the earliest in my
calendar most of my meetings would be 11
first meeting would be 11 movement
makers and brandedics I'll start at 10
30. uh and before that there's nothing
officially planned or scheduled so that
it gives my morning free to do whatever
I want to do and so if I want to go for
a hour-long believe walk instead of 20
minutes I can do that because I'm
thinking because I'm brainstorming
because I'm I'm
going through an idea I treat that as
walking meditation
if you like to meditate meditate I mean
it's the same thing I just find
meditation doesn't really help me that
much I like something a little more
active so I go I believe locks
do those two things
put on a playlist put on music every
morning
with lyrics that inspire you
and then go for a believe walk
20 minutes
to think about what you want to do today
what you want to accomplish how you want
to spend your time where you want to be
intentional
so you can start living the life that
you want to live
because the only thing that matters how
you feel about yourself
are you proud of you today
are you happy with what you've done
today
are you
joyful in how you showed up for you
today and yes we ultimately want to
serve and help others
but the only thing that matters
is how you feel about yourself
so we can stop relying on external
validation in somebody else's words of
affirmation for us to
feel Worthy
and flip it to say I am worthy I am
amazing
I can do great things
and when you can shift into that energy
you will do great things the beautiful
thing about monk life is half the day is
self and half the day is service that's
how you're taught to live okay so the
morning hours are for you to fill
yourself it's almost like putting on
mental emotional and physical armor like
that's what a morning routine is odd
days are tiring our days are busy our
days are draining well guess what if you
didn't put your armor on in the morning
and you're going out to battle
how many knives are going to cut you how
many swords are going to pierce you how
many wounds are you going to come home
with how many of you come back home
feeling wounded I come back home feeling
wounded sometimes but guess what if you
put your armor on in the morning a
warrior would never go out onto a
Battlefield
and life can be a battlefield work can
be full of conflict sometimes your
relationships can be damaging sometimes
your friendships can be toxic sometimes
so we are warriors in one sense and so
without wearing that so for me a morning
routine is putting on emotional armor
which is meant to protect you for the
rest of the day and that way even if you
do get pierced or you do get popped or
you do get cut you're protected and I
know that when my morning routine is at
its best I feel protected I know exactly
whereas when my morning routine is
weakened I feel weak and so for me the
morning routine as I get strategic about
it there's two principles you have to
know
location has energy and time has memory
if you do something in the same place
every day that place now holds that
energy
and this is huge like it's it's just so
big and I'm grateful for that reaction
because people don't realize how how
powerful this is like when I meditated
in temples that were 5 000 years old in
South India it was easier to meditate
because people have been meditating
there for thousands of years and so when
you find a space in your home and even
if you've got like I lived in a 500
square foot apartment in New York four
years ago and I just had a tiny Corner
which I dedicated to my sacred practices
so if you you don't have to have a big
home to do this you don't have to be
wealthy to do this you can find just a
corner in your home that you dedicate as
your meditation space or your reflection
space so first thing location has energy
second thing time has memory and this is
something that people underestimate when
you do something at the same time every
day
you remember it
and time remembers it that's why we
struggle to work out at different times
every day it's why we struggle like why
do we feel hungry at the same time every
day generally before hungry at the same
time most people if you've got regulated
diet you're full hungry you will feel
tired at the same time every day you
will look towards that coke can or that
sugar or that chocolate bar at the same
time every day
and so when you're meditating at the
same time if you're exercising at the
same time so what I recommend to people
wow is your morning routine needs four
aspects and it's simple and I call it
time it's about making time in the day
okay so time stands for t-i-m-e T stands
for thankfulness there needs to be even
if it's five minutes five minutes of
thankfulness of gratitude every single
morning and that has to be gratitude
that's specific it can't be gratitude
that's generic so generic gratitude is
something that anyone could be grateful
for oh I'm grateful for the sky I'm
grateful for air I'm grateful for water
that's cool but it's generic gratitude
specific gratitude is I'm grateful for
the fact that I have someone calling me
this morning I'm grateful for the fact
that I can still call my parents I'm
grateful for the fact that I have this
person in my business who is having such
an impact I'm grateful you know it's
specificity yeah so thankfulness second
one is Insight I think this is one thing
that a lot of people are missing which I
recommend people listening to you it's
like podcast books and and make it
easier for yourself if you get this book
leave it open on your bedside table
leave it open on your kitchen table
leave it open on your dining table I
guarantee you you will read more and
what you read will speak to you and I
think people underestimate that that
literally like when you have it open and
you'll just flick to a chapter randomly
and you'll pick up one line it will
impact you and it'll speak to you so
Insight you need Insight every day m is
meditation and I believe meditation is
different for different people as monks
we did walking meditations we did Beach
meditations we did visualizations we did
breath work find your meditation
practice I give a ton in the book and
fourth obviously exercise which you can
speak to even more than I can I exercise
to keep fit you look amazing too though
but it's an exercise everyone needs to
find five minutes a day 15 minutes a day
of exercise
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome to learn
to manifest The Impossible check the
video right there next to me I think
you'll love it continue to believe and
I'll see you there so to go about
wanting to manifest material abundance
in your life is perhaps not the the
right way to go about it because you're
all concentrating on the outermost layer
of abundance